Japan's imposing a series of new social
restrictions after a surge in cases of
coronavirus it's also urging its
citizens not to travel to 73 countries
and regions that's a third of the world
it's expected to close its borders to
people coming in from the u.s. from
Canada China South Korea and most of
Europe Japan has so far been spared from
a major outbreak that the number of
infections is approaching 2,000 now 56
people have died let's talk to our
correspondent in Beijing Katrina you and
Katrina
apart from that incident with that
cruise liner that was at Yokohama port
for some time we had thought that Japan
had escaped the worst of this and and
there is some suggestion that perhaps
there were some government manipulation
of information if you like whilst the
whole issue of the of staging the
Olympics was still on the agenda
that's right martine so it did look like
a very positive picture in japan given
its proximity to china the epicenter of
the outbreak we had some very low
numbers for a number of weeks and japan
avoided putting it its country into any
strict lockdown it avoided any severe
social distancing measures for some time
now as you mentioned cases in japan are
approaching 2000 which still doesn't
sound like very much compared to some
other countries but what is concerning
is how fast that number has jumped
that's nearly doubled in recent weeks
and because of this Japan is now
planning for some intense measures
including some travel bans the Japanese
government is planning to introduce a
travel ban on 73 countries as you
mentioned one third of the world
including the u.s. South Korea most of
Europe so what we've heard is that when
this ban comes into place any person
who's been in any of those 73 countries
in the past two weeks will not be
permitted to enter Japan the Japanese
government is also urging its citizens
not to travel to 50 countries in
particular around the world developing
economies now as you mentioned is
there's a bit of a scandal in Japan
surround
in prime minister shinzo are they
because the timing of these this spike
in cases was just after the postponement
of the Olympics was announced last week
leading many critics to say that a prime
minister a Shinzo Abe and his government
was purposely downplaying the
coronavirus numbers initially in order
to quell fears about hosting the
Olympics and that was also one of the
reasons he delayed putting any stricter
measures in place so at the moment
there's a lot of backlash from the
Japanese government saying that these
measures should have been put into place
much sooner especially now that Japan
seems to be struggling to contain a
particular fast-growing clusters of
coronavirus around the country